Her low freak bitches on his own shit,
you know,
but in any ways.
So we're having these arguments and then it would turn to a pejorative and I'm
like,
well,
okay,
why are you attacking me?
I'm not attacking you.
I'm not even being angry about your statement.
I just,
you,
you made statement a so I don't believe in it.
I don't,
I don't think that that's correct.
So we're having a discussion,
but now it became a,
a personal attack.
Not once even gets to that,
let alone someone,
even back in the day talking about,
oh,
it really upsets me that uh,
no matter how angry you know,
my,
whatever,
if I hit you or did this,
it wouldn't matter because you're you.
It's like,
well,
both of these statements come from the same,
same with both of those scenarios come from the same place.
It's like,
well now you're trying,
you're attacking me,
the individual.
Because if you're going to do that,
you aren't thinking about me as the person that's,
no,
no.
I got your back through heaven and hell,
I will kick the gates of hell down and kill everyone there.
If I got to the four year,
they're there.
They want to devalue a,
they want to devalue me,
the person,
because they,
they feel attacked in some way.
They feel like they're,
they're so attached to their,
to their statement,
to whatever that may be,
which has some attachment to maybe what they feel is their existence.
That to re to change that is dangerous.
To haul it outright wrong would be an even bigger problem.
And I mean,
you know,
I,
it's just like this stuff would start showing up at the house.
And so I'm like,
all right,
I'm going to start doing research on marks and angles and all this different
stuff.
And,
and then as I would go further and further and further down the rabbit hole,
I come back and I go,
oh,
okay.
So this argument stems from this and this and this and this and this.
And they're like,
no,
it doesn't like,
whoa.
Okay.
Uh,
why,
why do you think people operate?
Like,
what,
what do you think their whole reasoning is?
You know,
we get in these arguments about capitalism.
Capitalism is a neutral system.
Ask you this.
What is it about social justice warriors are left wing people that were Marxism
is so attractive to them.
Uh,
well for one it's,
it's this idea of equity,
like this sameness.
Like everybody,
nobody is being left behind and no one is,
is becoming greater than anybody else.
Uh,
it's also the idea,
I like to think of it in,
I think a lot of these young people look at it as grow mom's house,
mom and dad's house.
So when you're a mom and dad's house,
someone does your laundry.
Someone who cooks your food,
you know,
you always just show up.
You got a place to live,
uh,
you know,
the TV turns on and then the government should become mom and dad wants.
Exactly.
So they want mom and dad's house to exist forever.
So it's just like they can run off and do whatever it is they want to do.
Food.
There's plenty of money for shelter.
We just need to spend it.
Right.
The redistribution of wealth.
Right,
exactly.
Because if you exceed that system more than they deem that you should have,
then you should give it to somebody else and it's like,
well,
how do you think I got this?
Oh my God,
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Go ahead.
Keep going.
It's just like,
how do you think I got this?
Uh,
people can say,
well,
it was you got it through you and inherited it.
Okay.
That does happen.
I could also have got it through hard work and dedication and some,
some guile and some smarts and made it happen for myself.
Does that somehow mean that I had to do it at the expense of someone else?
Not necessarily shitty argument.
Right.
That's the,
but that's the argument that they keep pressing is that if you're successful,
you did it on the bits.
All grant.
It's all grift.
Yeah.
What do you think?
This is what I wanted to ask from someone else is an interesting thing too.
It's like if someone agrees to do a job,
if their skillset is limited in such a way that they were,
that they were capable of doing this job at this moment.
Now of course if you're asking me,
they probably they have a potential to do more than that.
As long as they're willing to invest back in themselves and find another skill
or expand that skill,
you know,
if there's always possibility for growth within a human being,
within their lot in life,
whatever that is and that that could be transferred into work could be
transferred into a personal goals.
I mean it's all about how you value things also.
So this person gets into this job working,
making widgets for this guy who invented this widget.
This guy invented the widget,
the argument that,
okay,
the worker deserves just as much as the guy that invented it.
It's like,
well hold on.
Without the guy that invented the widget,
you have no job.
Like all of these people that are working out on working underneath them,
we'd have nothing.
They would have zero,
there would be no widget to build.
And the guy that made the widget also has the most responsibility because he had
to come up with the money to produce the widget to be able to hire the people to
make the widget,
to then market the widget to do all these things to the widget to get it out
there to make it successful enough to then support more people and that doesn't
necessarily mean it's on the back of that other person.
Because you could also say,
well is everything on the back of the guy that made the widget?
I mean do you just,
his idea is not worth it is not,
can't be belonged to him because he created it.
We we,
we should take it for us even though we never,
we did not come up with it.
We never created it.
We didn't even have the facilities to make any created and didn't invent it are
the ones who want to define how much this guy should get for inventing it versus
how much they are.
And I would get into arguments with my ex about,
she's like,
oh,
I think all businesses should be co ops and my finger.
Like what does that mean?
Well like cooperative where everybody is getting an equal share and end into the
business itself.
Yeah,
I would say it is hilarious.
And also because I would say all businesses can be co ops.
There is no one's stopping a business from being a co op.
We know what stops businesses from being a co op is somebody doesn't want it to
be a co op or a,
someone decides,
well that doesn't,
I can't do it that way.
So it won't make as much sense for me to create a co op situation as it would to
not or a co op sounds nice and enforced.
Co-Op does not sound nice.
Of course.
Clop sounds nice if like say if you and I live on a block and we said,
hey,
let's,
we've got this fucking patch of land.
Let's start a garden started a little small farm.
Correct.
And we'll just have a little co op here.
Right.
All right,
cool.
Great.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
But that's not my choice.
Voluntary and says Josh Barnett,
is this the Josh Barnett Farm?
Yeah.
Well,
you're going to have to turn this into a co op and you're like,
what the fuck I am.
Well,
we're going to put you in jail.
Exactly.
And that's,
and then it comes back down to violence.
Here's the question.
This is what I kept meaning to ask before I forget.
Do you think that the,
what do you think the numbers are of the people that are involved in these ideas
that have never competed in anything?
Now that's,
my ex girlfriend is a professional fighter.
She fights and Bella tour.
However,
the idea of the meritocracy,
of being a fighter,
it seems,
it's not,
I don't think it's lost on her.
I just think that she,
she doesn't like the way it's worked out for her and that makes her an upset.
Whereas for me,
I found success as being a fighter.
And it sometimes it would,
it would appear that she would be,
she would be upset at me for what I was able to do and somehow think that maybe
I was less deserving or somehow,
um,
it's an exception that who knows what,
but the reality is,
is like I can sit back and go,
oh,
Mark Hunt just made $800,000.
Her thought might,
it might be more,
let's say if we're just,
I'm making this up.
I'm not saying it.
She said this,
you know,
she's like,
well,
why does he deserve $800,000?
Why I make a $4,000 or $5,000 or whatever?
Seeing people say that,
right?
It's just like,
okay,
well I could think of all plenty of reasons and go,
he draws more tickets.
He's got a better record.
He's,
he's one,
he's a k one she champ or whatever,
you know,
at the end of the day,
if any in New Zealand.
Right.
And if he's selling more tickets than you are,
then he gives it,
he deserves a greater percentage of that money now.
Now you come to me and I can be like,
well,
I beat Mark Hunt.
Right?
But what's her argument for that when you say that?
Uh,
her argument for that would be that,
you know,
this other person isn't any more deserving than,
so everyone should get paid the same.
So Jon Jones,
Fides,
Daniel Cormier,
Yay.
Huge fight.
Everybody on the undercard gets a fair share.
Well either that or just like,
well,
I deserve more than this and it's,
and my argument would always be [inaudible] when she was upset about what she
may be getting paid here or there and some of this,
I'd go,
we'll look,
you know,
for,
for this,
for what we're trying to accomplish and for what,
what is available in these markets.
That's not a bad payday.
Well that sucks.
No,
I agree with you.
You should make more money,
but we can't and it's not available.
So we have to deal with what we have for me.
And then I would look at something like Mark Hunt and be like,
well,
I beat Mark Hunt,
but so what?
I'm more glad that Mark Hunt was able to create an opportunity to make $800,000
so therefore,
if he can make $800,000 now the potential for me do that exists as well.
And it's just similar to like the old Gina Carano thing where everyone got on a
train about wanting to be Gina Carano fucked tuna crunch,
not even that good,
and blah,
blah,
blah.
All this hate at Gina Carano.
When the reality is like,
okay,
well even if you beat Gina Carano,
you're not going to get what Gina Carano gets.
You're not going to get,
people aren't going to like you just as much or more.
It's really not about any of that.
The only thing you can control is yourself.
At the end of the day,
you can only control yourself.
You can,
you only you can can work to try and increase or you're in determine your value
in terms of what you're trying to sell.
Okay.